philadelphia pennsylvania new york city
new york kippy and uncle hank are coming
home to roost baby october 27th helium
comedy club philly pennsylvania come and
see us and then for the new york comedy
festival we're gonna be at gotham comedy
club on november 9th these shows are
gonna sell out get your tickies
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage sure is it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they grow up to be
classy or if they're just a big old
piece of trash i'm your host stage foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at anthony's basement she's
upstairs she's all swole up all sore
milk crate challenge
i told her it's over she got hurt she
says she can bring it back on tick tock
okay so we'll see my co-host is coming
at you from right next to me he's the
ceo of are you garbage he's
international businessman i'll tell you
that right now he's not to be trifled
with in the boardroom especially before
he's at his coffee and his danish give
it up for kevin james ryan everybody hey
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are true
the roof through the [ __ ] roof baby
and then the greatest website of all
time
patreon.com garbage sign up you get
bonus episodes uh live streams the whole
[ __ ] nine yards check it out shout
out to the conte family and the yam
family and all their subsidiaries we
love you you're in our prayers nightly
and how about a quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man he
makes us all look good give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin it's toby mcmullen
what's up dudes what's up t-bone good to
see you buddy we got together when we
were
over the last week we had lunch oh great
we hung out we had a nice time
tweeted none of that [ __ ]
stayed clear of him but gang that is
neither here nor there we got a hot one
because we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly and i mean
incredibly special guest here with this
today not the usual bums and bozos you
see walking around here all right this
man is a legendary stand-up comedian
podcaster radio personality and actor he
has quite a few credits we're going to
go through a few of them we're going to
start off with ed the colin quincho
spider-man lucky louie 13 episodes grand
theft auto 4 zach and miri make a porno
cop out furry vengeance board to death
top five deadbeat louie ten episodes
benders the nick
inside amy schumer the jim gaffigan show
the comedian nightcap crashing power the
irishman martin scorsese ever heard of
him yeah all right i got tough crowd
with colin quim last comic standing
jesus host of the avian awards
jimmy kimmel the late show with david
letterman the jay leno show that metal
show dave's old porn late night with
jimmy fallon had a 10-year run with the
tonight show with jay leno chelsea
lately cop show four episodes should
have became a series wtf with mark maron
church of what's happening now joe rogan
he has multiple stand-up specials and
albums out to name a few
monster rain you got please be offended
american degenerate contextually
inadequate mouth full of shame and of
course he appeared on the opium anthony
show from 2001 to 2014.
he is the co-host of jim and sam on
siriusxm and the brains behind the chip
chipperson podcast but the big question
about his mind today yeah is he garbage
now i've heard the rumors i read the
newspapers but i got a feeling he's
going to surprise us ladies and
gentlemen again the legendary mr jim
norton everybody thank you
and by the way what you just said adds
up to more than the more dialogue that
i've had in all that [ __ ] put together
i'm i'm the king of one sentence and
done they're like get him out he stinks
hey man this guy my credit's a credit
you can still flex at cramped services
you know what i mean they don't know
what you're doing there i was in i was
in benders i was in the pilot which was
like uh uh mike uh christos stefano and
joel
yeah and uh i died of cancer in the
pilot episode
but i don't think i was supposed to
[Laughter]
it said series regular no no we're gonna
kill you off in the pilot episode
and bring the bus
[Laughter]
buddy thank you so much for coming and
sitting with us man we really appreciate
it you guys are great what is the uh
give me the origin story of mr jim
norton jersey kid right it's not
eventful it's bayonne uh born in bayonne
uh raised in edison okay my parents are
still married i have a sister and uh i
blew a lot of my friends
[Laughter]
ah just like norman rockwell painted it
folks
yeah there's a touching photo of me at a
diner with a policeman with his hand on
my head
oh man you gotta love it
uh what did your mom and dad do growing
up my dad is uh he was in the military
um and then he was in the post office
and uh then he joined the army reserve
so he's a postal employee army reserve
okay command sergeant major nice and my
mom was a librarian really yeah like
which is a weird like when she had my
sister then she kind of went out to work
like with me she i was raised at home um
which obviously it did not go well
i was raised at home and she's like i
don't want to make this mistake twice
maybe i'll leave the house um and she
was librarian so she used to bring me
home like comedy records like woody
allen okay robin williams and all that
[ __ ] and how far apart are you and your
sister i'm seven years older you're
seven years older than her okay and when
you say you were raised at home you
weren't like homeschooled or anything
like that right no no no no i mean just
like you know it was pretty my parents
uh my mom stayed home with me when i was
a kid gotcha you know it was fairly
traditional uh-huh dad worked mom stayed
home you're talking apartment
single-family house condo townhouse what
are we talking here apartment um in
edison um and then we moved into a house
in north brunswick because i remember my
parents paid fifty six thousand dollars
i don't know how i knew that but that
was the big that was a huge
number and the mortgage was like 700
bucks a month and i couldn't believe
that they were spending that much money
yeah you know that's that was definitely
thrown in your faces yeah you know how
much this [ __ ] house costs oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely
yeah you shouldn't know your dad's
mortgage payment i know
i don't know how i heard it's crazy it
was probably when one of them was crying
[Laughter]
screaming at each other in the kitchen
[ __ ] 600 a month reverse morgan son
of a [ __ ] what am i doing
upside down on a house in new brunswick
i knew that [ __ ] too and that does
affect you as a kid yeah when you know
like the finances and stuff like that
well my dad got laid off in like 1980 he
drove for hall's trucking this morning
post office
and there was that whole i he boys
blamed jimmy carter and i don't know if
he was his fault
gotta love a good vengeance
carter that's a new ru garbage question
does your dad hold any presidents
personally responsible for his
well-being
[ __ ] carter yeah yeah my dad drove a
peanut truck
but yeah he was fuming at [ __ ] jimmy
carter
was he a big reagan guy did he like
reagan i don't know i don't know if he
liked reagan or he just hated jimmy
carter
i don't even remember i just i know that
my dad couldn't get back to work because
uh he had this like the guy in the union
ahead of him
they didn't like so like my dad couldn't
get back to work because the guy ahead
of him was not going to come back
because they hated that guy okay so
that's why i learned about like the
unions and like you know sharks you're
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i like it and so
you're an 80s kid basically you you plus
my dad was smuggling drugs with the
truck companies really no
things are about to get real spicy in
here i like it i bought that like this
was wtf okay no no [ __ ] jim tell me more
[ __ ] idiot i tripped on smuggling it
deserved what it got which was what
i was like you lead with that you don't
lead with the carter's thing leave with
the drug smuggling
uh religious growing up
no i made um i did my catechism and
communion was like kind of like the
standard [ __ ] sure
but i know and i don't have any real i
think i had to go to ccd for a while but
it was like a regular i wasn't raised in
catholic school i just i didn't look
school the public school basic religious
[ __ ] you did uh my uh confirmation name
was christopher i don't know why i just
liked that that was a cool name yeah but
that was the end of my religious
training yeah yeah so your full name
would be james joseph christopher norton
yeah how do you know joseph i do my
wikipedia that's right goddamn that's
right the research department got a
couple of guys following jim around for
the last couple of weeks i wanted to
make a good impression on him my parents
weren't very hacky with the bible joseph
i mean come on
dug a little deeper than that you
[ __ ] ezekiel something
a little spice on it exactly would you
go to church once in 1965 and that's the
name you remember
my mom named me the corinthians you know
what i mean
jesus christ all right so we're talking
traditional
american family yeah what were the kind
of cars growing up
you know my dad uh oh this was we had a
chevy vega uh it was a hatchback a vega
hatchback hatchbacks are always tough it
was tough because we would go fishing
and i was such a dog [ __ ] fisherman
my dad put a fish on the back
i remember that was on the window no no
i wish it was on the windshield we never
it was on the [ __ ]
crazy
no it was on the uh it was on the back
on the back above the bumper and it was
so humiliating because he goes that's to
let everyone know there's a fisherman on
board oh god i was like oh
hi captain
really [ __ ] like that you know that
feeling you get where you're just like
it's it's a weird one you can't even
laugh off when you're a kid yeah
that's tough man your parents made you
feel awkward like that you didn't know
how to process you're just like oh
no
no he should have put like a [ __ ] a
thing with vinegar hanging over the
bathroom so everyone know there was a
couple of douches on board
how often would you take you fishing you
know we would go my friend bill d'angelo
was a good fisherman him and his dad
would go
and it's weird that you put pressure on
yourself about this that you weren't a
good fisherman well it was one of those
things that i would literally all the
other kids at school are making fun of
them
jim can't even catch a sonny
[ __ ] douche caught me two wide mouth
bounces here huh jim ain't caught
nothing yet well no bill would catch
fish with it they were like kind of
outdoorsy and i would literally it was
just humiliating because i would catch
nothing i hated fishing [ __ ] haters
because i caught in vermont my dad would
take me once in a while and we would
always throw the fish back we used to go
on like family vacations to vermont um
that's pretty nice
that's good yeah you do like the jersey
shore too at all or no
no no i don't know it's classy it was
classy jersey kid you didn't go to the
shore when you were growing up i don't
think so i was never big on the beach
because i was never in beach shape and i
never had the confidence you need to be
in a beach i hear you loud and clear jim
yeah but you're a little kid though
i knew at seven but i still wanted [ __ ]
these vermont broads won't know what hit
him
he's country folks i tell him i'm an
all-state fisherman oh yeah they thought
i was amazing yeah 30 miles from new
york whoa
and a hat that's what you're doing hey
i'm 30 miles from here yeah close to the
big apple
by the way just to go back those
hatchbacks when they started putting
those out they were such a big
transition from like station wagons and
regular cars they were a tough there was
a window where i feel they were before i
i was born in 86 so they were before my
time but i remember like there was the
still there like
kids that would turn 16 would be driving
them
like when i was a kid i remember i'm
like these look because they were only
crude for like six years yeah and then
like you're someone's driving them in
like the early 2000s you were like what
the where is this leftover from yeah it
looks like another planet it was a weird
car and i remember my mom had this uh i
don't remember what we had before that
but she had this weird ashtray with like
you remember the ashtrays that had the
sand like a little bag of sand oh yeah
[ __ ] they wouldn't tip they were awesome
that was a car ash tray and that was i
always remember my mom
smoking i could just remember going to
my grandmother's house listening to
philadelphia freedom by elton john and
my mother's smoking that's my biggest
memory in the car yeah her cigarette
smoke
what kind of things was she smoking
benson and hedges nice which is good too
because you like a nice three-hour smoke
cigarette
[ __ ] telly savannah she's gonna
she's got the 200's it's [ __ ]
sticking out the windows long thin it
looks like a bread stick yeah [ __ ]
those things are brutal man
holy [ __ ] did your dad smoke he did but
he quit probably before i was born he
said he just he just one time that i
threw up through the pacquiao and was
done so i think he quit i don't think i
ever saw my dad smoke okay and was your
family was your extended family around
the area my family was in ford's uncles
and aunts uh and we had family up in
massachusetts
um my aunt my uncle they were like the
good like the really rich
they were nice people but they were
really like you know he was an attorney
and they were really really well very
wealthy yeah nice people in
massachusetts uh and we were nice people
but we were we were kind of like you
know well yeah more working class the
garbage end yeah yeah of course yeah
would you go up and visit them yes yeah
would they be real snooty to you no they
were very nice a lot nicer than i would
have been if i had their money
believe me
these rats from jersey are here again oh
trust me when the [ __ ] [ __ ] nortons
came up from jersey it would have been a
different welcome god there's that damn
hatchback again close the gate close the
gate
yeah no they were really nice oh that's
beautiful yeah i still don't get to not
going to so vermont would be the
vacation spot
mainly yeah from what i remember i was a
very young kid um and i don't think i
went to the shore much i might have gone
a few times growing up but i never liked
the beach i just never i guess you know
what i mean because whenever you're
there you're just you're far from home
it's uncomfortable there's so much
sweaty yeah i mean when i was very young
they would take me but i never was never
enjoyed beach culture a day trip to the
beach when you're a little kid you're
going to get in there and then driving
back that's like that's like two tours
in vietnam it's [ __ ] it was brutal
yeah it was a long day
shower in public i got a car
or something yeah what the [ __ ] yeah
which i did bonnaroo actually it was uh
you performed there a few times yeah is
it good
it was okay it was better than woodstock
94 which we did a bunch of comedians
performing
jesus christ yeah it was it was an
abominable abominable for stand up it
was the smaller side sure terrible who
else went up bobby levy uh jeff ross who
was jeff schultz back then
um a comic named brick mason um jim
florentine don jameson rich voss and
yeah yeah all of us who peaked in 2007
and their time
now what about disney world they take it
to disney world never went no never went
no i went to universal with a girlfriend
when i was uh about
21 or 22. really she wanted to go down
there yeah we went on confrontation i
remember i went to uh universal and i
went on confrontation a couple of little
rides it was a shitty trip did you split
that did you pick up were you making
money at that time no i don't know if i
was doing stand-up i might have just
started doing stand-up um and i went
down there her dad flew down back then
you could change airline tickets like i
was scared i flew braniff air
and i was scared to fly so it sounds
like from the [ __ ] ussr
i don't know what happened to it was
probably like one of those startup
airlines they had like two planes yeah
yeah yeah
it's like wings
um and we wound up uh he just gave me
his ticket i just flew his ticket like
back then there was no it was wow
yeah like 1989 or whatever but no i
never went to disney world in my life
okay
vacation universal with your girlfriend
that's pretty garbage
yeah
would you fly to vermont or drive you
drove drove yeah yeah yeah okay was the
first time you flew
your adult life
the first time i can remember flying
was going to
it might have been that might have been
the first flight or it might have even
been
going to seattle
for the uh for a 12-step convention i
went out there okay i think i just
started stand up i was like six months
into stand-up i think that might have
been my first major flight okay was to
uh uh seattle how old were you when you
got your passport do you have your pass
i assume you have yours yeah yeah i'm on
my third one i think i was probably in
my
mid uh
teens early 20s it's pretty that's
average what does that mean third one
what you filled the book up every 10
years every 10 years you got to get it
again oh really yeah yeah so he's had it
for 30 years i guess i have right i
don't know yeah yeah yeah probably early
20s yeah where did i travel
internationally it was probably montreal
when i first started doing okay stand up
94 maybe i just got mine a week ago your
first one yeah 45 45 did you really yeah
why did you just get it because i never
had any reason to go anywhere where are
you going i'm gonna go to france at
christmas oh nice i did that a couple
christmases ago did you um yes and then
the year after i went to italy oh yeah
france is a nice place for christmas so
now you've traveled everywhere you've
been you've been around you've been
around the world sure that's what
happens if you don't have love or a
family
you can just go look at people who are
living full-time
in france
only guy at the eiffel tower on
christmas eve hey can you take this
picture for me
just me my thumbs up
let's talk about manscaped landscape
halloween coming up uh-huh you don't
want a couple of uh wild hairs coming
out boo scaring the [ __ ] out of you
can't be looking like a werewolf down
there you can't do it gotta be hit with
a silver bullet gotta get the manscaped
you gotta get everything trimmed up
organized nice and clean yeah they even
got refined body wash for the fellas the
ladies love it the signature scent the
whole nine yards
and plus you might scare away a couple
of vampires
i thought
[Laughter]
guys the lawnmower 4.0 we've said it a
time and time again it's fantastic they
sent us each the it comes in a box you
get the the ball tone of the whole nine
yards the body wash it's fantastic they
even got a set of undies you can get to
i mean it's plus the travel bags tight
you look yeah yeah come on what are we
doing you got to run a tight ship down
there you can't be you know no shaving
with a blading cream don't be using your
beard trimmer get the manscape lawnmower
4.0 you get 20 off and free shipping
with the code garbage at manscape.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
promo code garbage at manscape.com
say trick or treat to your beautiful new
halloweeny with manscape that's right
the way
kevin i want to talk to you about mint
mobile love those guys over mitt mobile
i want to talk to you about not getting
ripped off by the big
phone companies hate those guys the
contract despise them the this the that
the fine print the fine print you don't
got to deal with any of that with mint
mobile they pass the savings right onto
you and that's their secret sauce baby
first company first company to sell
direct wireless service online only
what are we doing it's called cutting
out the middleman cutting out the middle
the middle bozo yeah uh if you're
looking for some extra savings mint
mobile offers premium wireless for just
15 bucks a month all plans come with
unlimited talk and text high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan look at that keep your same
number along with all your existing
contacts i've said it every other time
my wife uses it still to this day been
using it for a while for years it's
fantastic it's easy peasy i want to
switch over but i'm all hemmed up with
these goddamn contracts crazy they got
me until my you know till my kid
graduates college coming and going um
get your new wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com
garbage cut your wireless build at 15
bucks a month you can't afford not to do
it crazy mint mobile.com garbage do it
bit mobile hold on would you really
travel by yourself no no no i mean i
have i have actually but not not that
often i don't like
i'm fascinated with people that can just
go away alone dude that's crazy
i just start i don't mind eating by
myself
i just i don't mind that i'm going like
sitting at a bar and like or wherever
and just eating by myself i can get down
with it i don't like it in a restaurant
on the road i got to do it a lot yeah
but when i'm home alone i like to eat it
and i like to i just watched lost or
something i've got my third watch of
lost i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
doing i watched seinfeld 15 [ __ ]
times i've never watched a lot of
seinfeld i've seen a couple episodes but
i was never i mean i looked out like wow
that was a brilliant writing really
great and great storytelling yeah but it
was never my show i never got you no do
you know seinfeld i know him casually um
i mean for a long time we say hello and
he's always friendly when i see him but
we've never like hung out hung out just
um you know but he speaks he's he's
friendly yeah yeah yep
very cool very cool i like it do you
make dinner at home a lot for yourself
well i actually had a dream about
seinfeld recently telling me why he
doesn't have me open for me it was such
a weird dream
comics will never get over it huh i'm so
bizarre he's like i like you but you
know you know you're a little dirty you
know something yes of course i don't
even want to open for him i'm too dirty
i would bomb but it's funny you said it
um oh yes i'm sorry man eating cooking
dinner at home alone would you make
dinner for yourself i've lived in my
place for five years and last night i
noticed that my oven light was on i'm
like is that always on i open up the
oven i still have cardboard in there in
the oven i've never used my oven holy
[ __ ] you never use my oven i order
everything out i eat a comedy cellar or
i go uber eats i cannot cook nice cannot
cook breakfast
um if if the uh one of our interns
doesn't bring it at work okay they do
that it's serious it's real nice you get
breakfast ever you get to order whatever
you want
watery eggs it's [ __ ] awful the place
downstairs that makes the eggs is not
exemplary no um yeah it's terrible guys
we shouldn't be getting breakfast
delivered i definitely shouldn't be
responsible for that yeah yeah
it's t-bone's new job we get a moons
over miami stat
yeah i like a good breakfast but uh no i
always eat out i've never i think i made
eggs oh gordon ramsay one time um i
guess he was on the show or something
and he said he challenged me to use his
recipe to make eggs which is awesome
it was really i imagine when he does it
[Laughter]
this has cardboard in it
set the apartment on fire i walked
through it and it was okay but um i mean
it tasted better than i would have made
it it was kind of fun to do it but i
just don't have that knack to cook so
every single meal basically that you
have is out yeah yeah i've only cooked a
few times in my life i just can't do it
i don't i don't have a desire to do it
because again i'm almost always eating
alone um unless i'm in uh a club or
whatever then i'd rather go out to
dinner with someone if i'm dating
someone and they cook i love that like i
love home-cooked food but i just can't
do it
what was the thanksgiving situation
growing up or the cooking situation when
you were a kid your mom a good cook yeah
she's decent uh i i would say the norton
meatloaf was it was never an
international sensation
ah shout out to the meatloaf
but i did enjoy it uh she went on this
time when she made couscous a lot which
was just crazy in the 80s
you know
yeah what the [ __ ] that's that's what
wasn't
like
who's coos in the 80s yeah couscous yeah
holy moly yeah she made couscous a lot
and we also had uh you know she made
nice food the norton portions were never
particularly large we had enough to eat
but they were just smaller portions okay
some did you guys do sunday dinners
no i mean on sunday we would just eat
like any other night
but it wasn't like an event like i know
what you mean like a sopranos family
thing we never did that we go to my
grandmother sometimes my dad's mom all
right uh my mother's mother lived with
us from 1980 on until she died and my
dad's mom we would go to sea for like uh
major holidays and [ __ ] like that your
mom's mom lived with you for a majority
of your childhood from about 1980 yeah
when i was in fourth grade up until i
was 19 when she died
had her own room
downstairs yes ooh was it converted into
an apartment for her uh yes the whole
downstairs was and i don't want to say
any names but after she passed away
someone used it to bring hookers in
i bet you it was your mom
i'm assuming seinfeld but we'll keep it
moving
but i'm getting caught up does it have
its own entrance
or did you have to bring the hookers
into like the foyer well you could have
went through the back door but that was
you could go you you'd walk in the foyer
and go either upstairs or downstairs to
her place or you could just come in
through the back or the garage but yeah
usually it was late so it would just
come in the uh
front door interesting yeah very nice he
likes the woman of the night i've heard
i have yeah yeah something wrong with it
um we don't judge here at are you
garbage in the garage yep growing up did
you have a second refrigerator in there
no we didn't no garage fridge no okay
that makes sense it all checks out
everything's fine you were a one car
family yes we were until my grandmother
uh moved in and she drove ironically an
escort
no relation
yeah a little a little blue ford escort
and uh yeah
begging for it i'll tell you that
yeah carr really liked me i swear
it's different this time yeah yeah
it wouldn't go until i put money in the
ashtray
[Laughter]
talk to a bigger car behind you
oh that's a good piece of business right
there yeah so we had uh two cars
whatever my dad had which i forget what
he got after a while might have been a
ford taurus or something okay and then
she had that so he kept it tight yeah
pretty nice did you go to college uh one
semester
b and three f's in middlesex community
college i got a b in english
an f in problems in statistics western
civilization and whatever the science
was out of high school
yeah high school dropped out so i was
trying to uh get credits that would
translate from college and high school
wow like that they had like this thing
at community college and i think the
english professor just took mercy on me
sure
i didn't do well why'd you drop out well
like what was the rehab and i was just a
mess it's funny
i'm going through my closet i just found
the thing where my dad had to sign for
me to get out when i was 17. but i
missed a whole like month or two of
school because of rehab so i was like it
was just a waste yeah i wanted to work
yeah you know so i started doing some
work what was your first job
first job was uh trying i wasn't even a
good job trying to sell usa today when
it was a new paper and going
door-to-door trying to sell
subscriptions selling anything
door-to-door holy [ __ ] sucks it's trash
it's the worst job ever it was horrible
and i was bad addicts i
i can't lie like that i'm not a good
salesman at all and so i would always go
like you don't want to buy a newspaper
do you
know i sold one and you got a [ __ ] for
every subscription you sold that is just
delivering papers yeah they always tell
you like hey you know some guys are
doing 400 new subscriptions a day and
you're like that's 400 i'm gonna make a
million bucks you know never pans out
yeah no no i did terribly i used to have
to sell i used to try to sell roofing
door-to-door i was like do you need a
roof and they're like no you're like all
right i got no argument for you yeah see
you later and most people wouldn't even
know if they needed it who the [ __ ]
would even know if there unless it was a
terrible leap yeah unless yeah there was
a hole in it that was the only way i've
never i never sold one so yeah that's a
rough sell any restaurant experience
working in restaurants no i never worked
in food i i worked in a uh
trousers and it was um
that's a jersey uh
a jersey staple and i was working and
the food i noticed a lot of the cheese
and stuff had little teeth prints in it
um so i was like oh it looks like little
duties around it so i realized mice were
coming in
and i told my district manager at the
time
and he goes we'll just slice around it
like meaning like slice like an inch
deep and sell it anyway son of a [ __ ]
yeah that was really bad news but i was
just telling people don't eat it yeah
mice
so yeah no never arrested that's as
close to every game okay um was that
your grocery store growing up is that
where your mom went stop and shop stop
and chop tonight stop and shop and
bradley's right next door which was my
first retail job
i think i worked at stop and shop too
but we had a stop and shop a p was a big
one around there but i think stop and
shop was our go-to they're probably
jersey bradley's didn't sell food you
mean the bradley was like a department
store yes yeah yeah yeah super the uh
the retail store i was in menswear just
folding shirts and you know three hours
a night i think six to nine not bad not
bad no not bad
getting that first like 35 dollar check
you were like what was amazing yeah like
you know i mean the first time you get a
check with your name on and you put this
like this money there like do a little
overtime and make an extra like eight
ten bucks you like i couldn't believe it
i know i got too shabby did you how long
did you live at your parents did you
stay close to 30.
you literally lived at your parents
until you were 30. it's it's [ __ ]
easier to get rid of pancreatic cancer
than it was to get rid of me i just
stayed man
30 years old doing gigs and i was just i
wasn't making any money for the first 10
years but yeah yeah of course damn yeah
30. that's [ __ ] terrible
yeah how bad was the drive into the city
for spots or would you train um i would
drive uh and it was bad i was driving
sometimes twice a day once for an
audition in the afternoon then come home
then go back in at night to do my sets
it was a lot whose car were you driving
uh i think i got a car after a while my
dad oh you know what we had a uh what
did i have a topaz i had a topaz and my
dad
was like cigarettes yeah it was it was a
weird like uh it's a tough look it was
not a great car it's a who makes it four
topaz i think it wasn't mercury i don't
remember fordham mercury i think it was
ford my dad had that and then gave it to
me then he got the taurus oh yeah let me
see the topaz yeah that's 1994 right
there yeah the topaz i i will say this
there was not a lot of vagina filtering
not a lot that looks like a car where
like one of the doors doesn't open yeah
or the hood's gonna be a different color
yeah yeah something yeah i i got a few
few uh good good gears out of it but uh
that was that was a rough drive and then
i bought a mustang a black mustang
what year are we talking
i want to say 1990 so it was one of
those ones that everybody hated i guess
so you didn't realize it at the time
they were like when they got shitty
rear-wheel drive i know which is
probably standard in the mustang
and i remember
i was just starting comedy or might have
been 91 i was like i'll be headlining in
a few years and the payments were like
270 a month and i was i couldn't make
that
yeah
no i mean my parents taught me one of
these
yeah i think so it's black was it a 5.0
oh
i
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah no good
probably beating the ladies off with a
stick though huh nah not really at all
what about now you got a whip now
now i lease uh mercedes
love that money take that bradley's huh
beans don't burn in the kitchen yeah
nice a general a gentleman's vehicle i
like a gentleman's vehicle and the least
i think is the gentleman's move
yeah because it's a write-off because i
use it almost primarily exclusively for
work there you go so it's not 100 but
you say yeah you write some of it off
and um and i'm like then i can just give
it back in a couple years i like renting
leasing a nice car yeah fantastic and
not to get too specific but i assume
that's parked in the garage
in the building i don't have a garage in
my building but i have this i heard you
had a nice place yeah don't you were
caked up what's going on you don't got a
garage they don't have one in the
building uh but there was one like four
buildings down and now because the
pandemic they went out of business so
now i'm parking three blocks from my
house in a garage in a garage they're
not sitting in the car for two hours on
alternate side oh no no because then i
did that though when i lived in
cliffside park with jim florentine uh i
not altered this but i would have to
park a certain way
you notice how do it now that was back
in the day though that was
1997. you're not doing that now you got
a nice place you got the mercedes elise
yeah into into a garage will you are you
is there any plans for you to move out
of your place
no i love where i live you love where
you are yeah yeah this is it yeah i mean
the windows are leaky pieces of [ __ ] but
i'm not working on that
yeah it's very frustrating been driving
me crazy i said it like he's trying to
reconnect with his dad or something i'm
working on it i know
i'm talking to people about it we're
both in therapy yeah
all right that's pretty good that's
pretty good
uh when you fly do you fly first class
what do you do yeah i mean um i flew
coach for the first x amount of years so
now
it's uh usually if you fly for a network
or if they're doing anything they'll
always fly it's pretty standard for
anybody performing but um yeah you get a
buy out for uh
travel yeah
i love it look at this because we if
we're like i sit and i'm like i so want
to just spend the extra money on first
class we'll use miles i got silently we
had a thousand miles we just started
collect just started collecting
this is all new dog we've been we've
been successful for like three months oh
yeah yeah yeah i just
yeah yeah that's cool yeah it's good
literally new money baby yeah i love it
new cash new money i vow to blow all the
money
what's the uh any idea what the credit
score is
no it's pretty good because i pay
mortgage i'm like a [ __ ] my mother
was great with money so like i pay
mortgage i pay to my principal like i
don't spend you know again at least a
nice car but i don't go crazy and i
don't waste a lot of money so i think my
credit's probably good yeah but uh years
ago i got a little messed up a little
turn around because i didn't realize
that there were certain people you
shouldn't use your credit card with uh
that you would meet out of screw
magazine
and i used my credit card quarterly
selling those door to door i had ten
thousand dollars worth of bills racked
up by people who stole my number so that
took a while to work through damn screw
magazine well yeah the uh the young
ladies there some of them took credit
cards kid likes it old school
[Laughter]
he's an analog man my kind of guy brick
and mortar kind of guy
forget about the apps i like the hard
copy all right likes to feel the knife
go in you know what i mean
i just sit around and press a button i
can't come unless there's a paper trail
he's got ink on his fingers uh speaking
of cards um
mx card
i had one i should have kept it because
it gets you into all the lounges like at
the airport right but i got rid of it i
don't know i think they stopped
transferring miles
to uh like american or united so i have
like american and united cards that i
use but uh i should get that again just
to get into the [ __ ] lounge
no black card no amex no they're black
but not because it's a black card no mx
no okay i don't spend enough with them
all right all right all right be cooler
if you did i know i know i would love to
i would love to have an amex black car
but
um also real quick getting an escort on
credit is maybe one of the most garbage
things you've ever heard of honestly
yeah it's understandable yeah as long as
you pay your bill at the end of the
month you're actually saying no that's
what are you talking about that's it
these aprs are super low right now cash
transaction come on
cash unless you're paying in bitcoin or
something
cash yeah but then 10 years later you
really just spent 300 000 on a [ __ ]
it's like that pizza guy who was
accepting bitcoin
he's a billionaire
man that's a good piece of business
kevin i'd like to talk to you about a
new product called dad grass love dad
grass all right not even a dad and i
love dad grass of course now you know i
like to uh
you know right pop the cheap off the
chiba panama red over there however
problem is sometimes you do too much and
you get all [ __ ] anxious and paranoid
and you don't need that yeah bad grass
has figured that all out who doesn't
love to trip down memory lane that grass
takes you back to a fine time when music
was on vinyl
the hangs were actually hanging out
and the weed didn't send you to the
freaking moon
they're frying eggs off in the emergency
room yeah that grass is uh legal organic
smokable hemp that relaxes your body
mellows your mind 100 organic pre-rolled
joints are very low in thc high in cbd
so you can enjoy the effects of cb cbd
while keeping your clear head that's
right getting all foggy all smoked up
yeah now getting all jacked up like
these tick tockers yeah all dad grass
products are federally legal for ages 21
and over and ships right to your door
anywhere in the u.s where they're
looking for a buzz or chill way to enjoy
some old favorite stuff that grass is
the way to go right now dadgrass is
offering our listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to dadgrass.com
garbage go to dadgrass d-a-d-g-r-a-s-s
dot com garbage for 20 off your your
first order that's
garbage do dadgrass.com
kippystamps.comstamps.com i'll say it
one more time for the back of the room
stamps.com we use them we love them
we're small business owners yeah you're
a small businessman we got a lot of
small business owners we have a lot we
have a lot of go-getters out there and
being a go-getter being a small business
owner there's a million different things
you have to do you got to look over your
shoulder here here the other way this
that the thing the last thing you want
to do is waste time in the post office
getstamps.com do everything from the
office send it right out the door yeah
it's fantastic all you need is a
computer and standard printer no special
supplies or equipment needed but you can
we got the package they sent us yeah we
got that proper printer nice thermal
john sweet he's got the rolls of paper i
feel like i feel like i work at ups it's
fantastic it's a good feeling saves you
so much time so much energy uh and once
you're everything's all said we send out
all the merch with it once everything's
all set they can schedule a pickup
they'll come pick it up for you that's
nice we got it right next to our right
next to today so we walk over dump it in
but we're in and out in two seconds
stretch the legs a little bit you know
get the cardio in um you could still
smell the bernie's on us when we walk in
and walk out yes
cut the confusion out of shipping with
stamps.com uh they have the rate advisor
tool you can compare the shipping rates
between timelines everything you need
it's idiot proof the big man could do it
i don't let him but he could
uh save time and money with stamps.com
there's no risk our promo code garbage
you've got a special offer that includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts cancel any time you want
easy peasy just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the home
page type in garbage that's stamps.com
promo code garbage stamps.com never go
to the post office again now back to the
show to the show all right let's get
into some more you can hold on i got why
why we're why we're on the plane will
you take your shoes off on the plane i
literally as i'm walking down the jet
way
off
immediately my feet don't stink but i
think of it sometimes too like i know
that this is probably but it's just too
uncomfortable i'm too uncomfortable when
i fly okay and then will you take food
on the plane like when you get like a
cheeseburger at the shake shack and take
it off no very rarely again i'll bring
some pretzels um a little bag of nuggets
um just to settle my stomach
and cause i'm a little queasy flyer and
that's a very kind of base for your
stomach or an rx bar but i'm very simple
with what i bring on okay that's good
okay clean socks i assume oh yeah you
fly fresh uh usually going to a gig uh
but typically the same pair on the way
back so i would say
if you catch me going to annapolis it's
fine but coming back to the pilot if
you're on a plane to new york with jim
it's gonna be ugly socks got some miles
on them yeah yeah neck pillow
i have it but i don't use it okay they
don't work in the in pr in practice i
don't get them they never
you're too lean over they don't they
don't do it what i do is i take it
because i'm a bet and i'll take it and
actually reverse it and put the fat part
into my neck so i just kind of go like
that and lean forward a little bit but
i'm too antsy on a plane i can't sleep
yeah yeah i can't either you don't do
the eye things do you
no i have uh i have them uh it's funny i
have a pair that i never used and i just
found another pair and i saved them i'm
like why do you say this [ __ ] like i'm
never going to use it um but yeah steve
aoki i heard him talking about eye
patches he said he gets the ones that
don't touch your eyes and they're easier
to sleep with like they're like little
bee eyes they kind of dome over i got
you much more comfortable like those i
can actually use things i'm pretty
classy i know at home what are you
sleeping like you got a fan directly on
you i have a fan and i have a uh a two
ac units in my bedroom and i also have a
uh air purifier that blows really good
strong air it's got to be frigid in my
room right really yeah
i like it two ac's are they is it
central air conditioning or is there
window units they're you not window
units they're wall units because i have
like the high windows
in new york that's classy in new york
very split units you've got two of them
a fan and an air purifier yes um and i'm
a very i have a sleep apnea issue which
i can't use i just tried to use it two
nights ago and again it's blue
you know 30 seconds later i take it off
and i have my mouth guard and i hate it
so yeah sleeping on my [ __ ] you got a
mouth guard i do yeah okay what's the
mouth guard for it keeps me from dicks
going in
the mouth guard can't resist
where can i pick one up
i know the mouth guard does what my
upbringing couldn't
so uh yeah i uh the mouth card no it
pushes your jaw like
yeah and you don't choke on your own
yeah opens up your it'll yeah helps you
okay so it's a sleep apnea kind of thing
yeah your jaw falls back and closes your
throat i just did what i got second
sleep study and what are you what are
you uh i got a bad i got a bad yeah bad
news oh is is it uh is it extreme or
like extreme
yeah like mountain dew [ __ ] extreme
talking code red over here sponsoring
the x games
red bull wants to get involved it's
[ __ ] bad so is it the uh because i
have two kinds like and uh it's for me
it's just my my tongue just keeps
hitting the back of my throat and i have
central do you just have the obstructive
uh i think i have both where your tongue
goes back and the other one is when your
brain doesn't send the sleep signal so
yeah sometimes i'm just laying there
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] and nothing
happens and i'm like you're not
breathing and i wake up and i have to
breathe yeah it's weird man i i thought
it was anxiety or panic when i because i
for like the last seven years every
couple of minutes i just wake up
like that i didn't know it was [ __ ]
something serious can you sleep with a
mask on the thing that they i couldn't
do the test with the two nose things
going up my nose i just laid there yeah
i just laid there and watched the many
saints in newark they kept coming in
like i was wow if that didn't put you
out
oh man stinkeroo
i wanted it to be good too yeah uh
yeah they kept coming in like i was at a
sleepover just like go to bed go to bed
finally i fell asleep and then i went
back again and they put this mask on me
and i don't know how old yours is but
this is like something out of superman
it's that's like perfectly soft it's it
it's beautiful like i can see it really
working i haven't got oh man i'm jealous
you can use it yeah i i uh
i wound up going for two or three i
realized i just looked at my medical
thing a couple days ago to see if i can
reset my machine and i realized it was
2012 i went for my test oh [ __ ] um yeah
they've made major advancements i'm
hoping they have this made out of wood
a guy blowing in a tube yeah
night night jim yeah yeah this is just a
guy there in my closet
there's a girl queefing
that's not gonna go but no i want to try
to get but the masks my nose are all is
all messed up the mask kind of does that
and i can't breathe through it like i
hate the feeling of the mask right there
sure yeah my dad see that we have a you
know like something that would look like
you would get like if you got oxygen
yeah it's like that but it's tiny and
just goes over your nose and it's super
super soft my dad has the [ __ ] plugs
that go up his nose yeah he looks like a
scuba diver in the 20s wait it doesn't
you don't have one over your mouth too
no just goes over my nose how does your
mouth like i tried that and then i would
wake up like this he kept eating it
they are flying out of my mouth it's
funny because my nose is a little
stuffed up when i first went in and he's
like you need to start
training yourself
to breathe through your nose like a
normal person that's that's what they
said they said that the the that
breathing through my mouth a lot of that
is like a behavioral thing he's like you
have to like it's almost like um
like meditation he's like when you lay
down you have to
and get that and get that thing
yeah it makes me panic just thinking
about it my buddy does it and he said
that he puts a piece of tape over his
mouth before he goes to bed to make sure
he breathes through his nose is your
buddy chris angel
sleep freak
that's what you got to do man
could you text me the the model you have
because maybe because that sounds like
maybe uh it's better than the one i have
100 i absolutely will i had a mouth one
that goes over here and then the every
girl is officially tuned out
i have a refer friend policy at my sleep
after the incentive i just made 50 bucks
get on screw magazine get my own broad
okay i'll get these birds think
i'm trying to get a good night's sleep
over here
i have one that goes over my mouth and
then blows air up the nose maybe i'll
try that but yes if you can let me know
cuz i'm interested i got to start using
yeah that's that's like test pilot yeah
yeah it's uncomfortable and how many
pillows do you use
i probably have six or seven in my bed i
sleep on at least three yeah this is my
head propped up what size bed we talking
queen king gabby king and everything has
to be a king bed i don't know why i need
a big bed this guy's pretty classy no
the pillow that's complete trash and the
fans and the nine air conditioners i
[ __ ] love it it's garbage he's got a
king-sized bed though come on yeah he's
sweet yeah it's big but if i feel the
more pillows you use to go to sleep the
trashier person you are
yeah i mean honestly i said they're on
the bed though you're not using all six
or seven no no no i got one between your
legs no you hug one i don't know you
don't hug one well uh i i wouldn't say a
hug
yeah i i put it behind me and i cry
myself to sleep
no i wound up uh i was actually wrapped
in one last night but no i don't i want
to try one of those heavy blankets i got
one does it work they are fantastic
really
it just
and what i have a lot of anxiety and
stuff like that uh and then it just yeah
just kind of you don't realize it just
sues you how many pounds we i got that
my wife ordered it's the heaviest one
it's like 25 pounds or 20 pounds or
something what if something happens you
got to get up and kick some ass in the
middle of the night yeah i mean yeah
it's not like it's not made out of lead
it's a blanket at the end of the day
it's like a night sleeping on you
chainmail
i'm listening all right
very nice
i mean we're already into it we're
already knee deep in it here um
are you a uh somebody hit us up with
this uh and i i loved it i wanted to ask
do you drive to say you're going to like
a wedding or something like that well
you keep a t-shirt on drive there and
then put the shirt on when you get there
so you're all fresh or no
yeah but because it's basically
uncomfortable to to drive with that type
of clothing i'm with you i'm with you i
love it i do the same thing yeah yeah so
you'll throw it on in the parking lot
always that's always do you own a suit
i do yeah but i put weight on and it
doesn't fit me anymore and i'm like very
unhappy with it so i want to get down to
that suit again it's a great suit i
bought it for the tonight show years ago
it's a really would you drop on it five
thousand
what yeah maybe holy [ __ ] how much did
you get paid for the scent
it's still 1200 and that's [ __ ]
garbage baby i love that
but it was one of those ones where i was
doing it all the time and it was bad it
was a barney suit i went cry i never
splurged on clothes you can see how i
dress like i dress like [ __ ] i never
splurge on clothes and this time i love
that i wanted a nice
suit and a nice set of shoes i'm like
which i was going on regularly and i've
used it again for 10 years until i put
weight on so i it was a good purchase
because it's actually a really great
suit is that your only suit though
i have a few
but none of them uh but that's your
go-to that it was yeah until i had to go
to an event right before the pandemic
right and i realized it just it wasn't
fitting so i had to get another suit so
now i have how much was that one
cheaper that was like 2500 or something
still pretty good this guy's got some
games suits 100 bucks 200 bucks i've got
a few of those too yeah i got a few of
those too
huh i like it yeah right
thought that was a great question that's
awesome yeah it was good um have you
ever worn pants that zip into shorts
no i have not but i but i would really
not beneath me
i would not for etiquette purpose
i just can't get my hands on a pair i've
just never seen them and i wouldn't like
the way the zipper felt on my leg yeah i
don't like the way metal would feel on
my bare hand they have like a flap that
covers it oh my step dad's big into him
it's the thing at the house yeah
have you ever bought any food in the
subway
churros the fruit is in the train
station subway not with the subway this
restaurant i mean the subway oh yeah
yeah there's a train station yeah no
never no just like again not anything
that wasn't packaged like pretzels or a
[ __ ] bag of chips you still take the
subway yeah i will i have it in a while
i stopped taking the subway but yeah
what's going on it's just yeah crazy
yeah yeah plus the whole thing i used to
really i love licking the rail and i
just can't do that anymore i was such a
time killer
for hours oh my god i end up out at the
airport all of a sudden i'm licking
enjoying all your 72nd street yeah but
no i haven't in a while because it's
gotten to a little bit too crazy and
there's too many people uh it's just too
unpredictable sure of course i get it
and it's also my schedule chain so it's
just easier to hop in an uber and go
home yeah yeah i like it i live five
blocks from the subway so uh i have a
quick one in it it'll have an asterix on
it because it's work but long story
career have you ever been on an event or
a show that also featured limp bizkit
i don't believe i have unless they were
at woodstock 94 and i didn't know they
were 99. they were oh they were for sure
yeah they were the ones that yeah they
were okay i don't believe i've ever been
on anything have you ever met fred durst
no never met fred durst really yeah i
don't believe so t-bone brought it up
before but have you ever been to a chris
angel david blaine or siegfried and
roy's show
no
uh or hung out with any of them uh david
uh
david blaine i hung with the seller one
night when he came in
um he came in with edward norton many
years ago this is probably around 2000
um and we've uh interviewed chris angel
um
so no i've never really hung out with
him and who siegfried and roy
no i helped them train one of the tigers
[Laughter]
okay okay
do you know any good magic tricks do you
pride yourself on a magic trick by any
chance i don't know no not at all you
have any roadies in your family anybody
that was a roadie
no that would be a great that would be
great cause they hooked you up with
concert tickets no i don't have any no
roadies in my family any guys with
ponytails
no but my father is trying to grow one
at 80.
really no it's just pubes
[Laughter]
um what about you do you ever have uh
did you ever have a mullet or pierced
ears or anything like that never pierced
no tattoos um but the my hair is a
source of torture because i have
cowlicks so it would always like
mcdonald's m okay it looked awful so i
used to put bobby pins in my hair and
when it was wet to comb it straight to
try to get a bowl look a real
douche and i would go to this barber who
i now realize was a homosexual like i
didn't realize that but he was kind of
hitting on me when i was younger he
would press like his pubis against my
arm yeah and i never realized like oh
yeah that was very homoerotic he was
trying to [ __ ] me i think he would talk
about porn and different ethnicities and
how hard their [ __ ] would get how did
you know that how did that not register
i was just taking in the information
so he's got a notebook yeah yeah
jamaicans wasn't two years later i put
two and two together
and uh he would call he would do my hair
he would like spray it back like almost
like slicked back and it was so bad i
had a horrible [ __ ] hair okay ever
wore like a kangal hat oh my god yeah a
lot really long before it was
fashionable i don't think it was ever
fashionable yeah but i was too fat laces
back in the old run-down days yeah yeah
yeah try comedy oh pre because you would
get 16 17. you would okay that's i'll
allow that i was teenage angst white
jimmy trying to fit in in new brunswick
yeah yeah yeah what did you guys call
those laces because when i was a kid we
called them new yorkers those fat laces
they were called fat laces um although
uh they were basically uh douche
identifiers
and i certainly ah
adidas yeah yeah adidas yeah um hmm
everywhere a chain wallet
never had a chain wallet or did
you know i i don't remember to me the
rock wallets with the velcro were cool
those are yeah we thought those were
pretty awesome yeah they were hot for a
minute did you have a shark watch back
in the day never had a shark washer that
was a circle yeah i think he would have
been a little too old for the shark
watch
were you a boy scout no never back to
the suit i forgot to ask do you know how
to tie a tie
um i'm not properly um i've tied one but
then i accidentally threw it over
something and tried to go to sleep
no
no i cannot tie a tie
doing all those tonight shows who's
tying the tie my manager or someone in
wardrobe i mean really yeah yeah
catch a big star what are you talking
about i know it's one thing to not know
how to do it you know
to have to have someone do it i can't do
it i've tried to i just i'm not i don't
have the dexterity brush your teeth in
the shower
uh no
no after pee in the shower
yeah okay yeah and [ __ ]
hey guy lives alone
i mean at the ymca
schmitt let them know who's around you
know what i mean
yeah i'm like vito's kid on the sopranos
what a deep cut that's crazy i can
picture the scene exactly yeah i know
hurry up and finish that there's no
eating in the car
[Laughter]
oh man um
a drone
um any kind of magnets on the fridge you
collect magnets i know you're an
autographed guy picture guy
what's on the fridge nothing nothing not
just plain
big-screen tv yeah yeah you i do i i
went with the the giant
um
wheeled one and then it went down to the
wall you know the one it's not one of
them curved ones are they because they
were big for a little i almost bought
one but i was like no i'm i'm patient
with technology like yeah yeah like i'm
not getting the new iphone like i i not
storming the beach on the first night
never no cause there's always problems
and the curved one i was like that's not
there yet yeah it wasn't it did it go
away oh yeah nobody [ __ ] a couple of
weeks yeah yeah that and the 3d never
caught on either 3d i didn't buy either
uh
it's mounted on the wall now oh yeah
yeah yeah cool
um it's classy what do you do what do
you do for thanksgiving
you know it depends i'll usually go see
my family or i'll go up and see like bob
kelly i've seen him a couple of times
and see my parents went to amy's like
two years ago okay just see a friend
okay
classy growing up was always traditional
thanksgiving you guys never went out my
question is did you ever go out a
restaurant no we would always go to my
grandmother's house we would eat at home
and then go to my grandmother's who was
an amazing cook classy um anyone in your
family ever been interviewed on the
local news for any reason
no i don't think so okay good question
no i don't believe so any lawsuits class
action i was growing up you were super
oh yeah for what i was sued for
defamation
by a lawyer because we i made fun of him
when he called into the opium anthony
show i mocked him for an hour he called
back and then he challenged me to a duel
and then he sued me for a half a million
dollars what and it was a nightmare to
go through oh god dude it was i learned
so much about the law and defamation and
getting eno insurance and i had really
good lawyers and they were really nice
lawyers but this guy was alert so he
didn't pay legal fees bastard so he
wound up by yeah we wound up but we
never settled for any money he dropped
it when he realized how high my legal
fees were i was like that's enough
payment oh no yeah but we were going to
sue him for them
[Applause]
they were so egregious we thought the
lawsuit was 150 grand in legal fees
that's a law it's a law word agreement
oh yeah yeah you didn't know that word
before he dropped e and o insurance too
like i'm supposed to know what the [ __ ]
that is errors and omissions insurance
this way if you can't be suitable you
could be super you have insurance for
what you say um
yeah we gotta get our hands on some of
that [ __ ] and that guy a footnote that
guy recently was in the news because he
shot and killed a judge
in new jersey oh my god that guy royden
oh yeah and then he shot himself yeah
that's wayne [ __ ] yeah that guy sued me
he showed up at their house and didn't
he shoot the sun too he shot him sorry
he didn't shoot ipod he didn't shoot his
jaw he shot the son and the husband at
the judge's house yeah yeah yeah yeah
not the judge yeah what yeah yeah so he
was serious about that duel you know
it's fine i remember that like wow
what the [ __ ] challenged me to south
africa to a duel and we made fun of his
hip-hop dancing i mean the man was an
ass uh we made really good fun of him
oh yeah yeah
i would have i would assume the
radio stations
did they support at all or was it like
don't they have dual insurance
by support do you mean uh if they winked
and said good luck kid
go get a
tiger yeah they're very morally
supportive
grab a jousting stick and go head out to
the parking lot jim i got a bull brew
vest if you want
this duel
yeah holy [ __ ] cuz you guys would say
some wild you guys did
insane [ __ ] but you learn about
defamation like they you know o and a
were pretty smart about it and that was
my because you can't always predict what
someone's going to react to sure um but
yeah that was a that was a rough one
went on for a year jeez that sucks kevin
i'd like to challenge you to a dude okay
rock paper scissors
keep it fair um do you have a favorite
uh cup or spoon or anything like that at
your house or a go-to bowl
no no bowls and the cups i literally
have chip merchandise like the bolt like
the cups and i drink out of those
actually drinking out of your own merch
oh you kidding me i would [ __ ] wear
it right now if it fit me i just i
bought all mediums yeah the chip stuff i
will not jim norton stuff yeah not not
jim norton stuff yeah yeah i'm not a
lunatic i'll only drink my alter ego
this guy's bonkers oh man
holy cow have you ever uh been to a
harlem globetrotters game i have yes
what and i was so upset that curly neal
wasn't there and then one of the guys on
the the court took his wig off and we
realized it was curly neil he was bald i
was so happy yes my dad took me to see
the guy as a kid i really watch over the
edge
[Applause]
and it was still in the meadowlark lemon
days
but what's that i don't know
better like lemon he was one of the
original globetrot he was one of the
most famous i was more of a generals guy
myself yeah
oh he's thought that tom bishop on the
generals he was my guy yeah i don't
remember i remember like lemon curly
kneel and i knew all their names at one
point really yeah
i guess
best record in basketball i'll tell you
that say what the [ __ ] you want
uh have you ever owned a chia pet no
okay do you eat your pizza crust oh yeah
okay yeah you'd love it can you take
pills dry
no
stuff like that no i take a pill though
i don't i put water in my mouth i always
hate people to put on their tongue and
then drink the what the [ __ ] wait you do
water first i hold my water in my mouth
and go and suck it in so it's always
water i just swallowed it no that's
wrong that's wrong but it never touches
i have to call somebody and tell them
that what's that i don't know if we're
allowed to let you leave here
when you do that you can't do that it's
the best way to take a pill i don't want
that chalky [ __ ] on my tongue
pills taste awful
and i just
swallow it it's like [ __ ] swallowing
a goldfish with what it never goes it
never touches my mouth i just swallow it
you're gonna drown on tylenol yeah
that's crazy
yeah that's why yeah that's that's goofy
yeah understandable you floss every day
i do yeah but you do my teeth yeah i do
floss wow yeah
water pick
i just got a water i imagine i would use
one but no i prefer just the regular old
uh floss
mouthwash
sometimes yeah
neither i use this alcohol free stuff
because this the alcohol dries your
mouth out oh yeah bad
yeah so i'll use like uh with no alcohol
blistering and just to go back into the
shower what are we using body wash bar
soap soap bar soap what do you got i
have just probably irish spring nice
smell yeah a nice irish spring good
smell uh yeah i know and so all these
credits you're still using you're buying
off the rats and blue and that but i
bought the fancy copa soap at like those
walk around uh like festivals and uh you
know the one that has like oh it
exfoliates and i'll use those sometimes
but uh then they wind up annoying me and
i just go with the irish spring scrubber
or straight bar to bar to body bar to
body
body this guy is jersey trash baby but
you're right a loofah i used to have and
it does help exfoliate the skin i just
stopped using it music playing while you
shower you put you get the nose going no
i i like to think in the shower i like
it silent i just kind of stand there
like a ghoul and i think i do a lot of
thinking in the shower and i talk to
myself there's a there's a whole sodium
it sounds fun i like that about why that
works it's the the sound the the white
noise helps clear your brain it does
right yeah i like that feeling it's just
a place to zone out i love i love just
kind of being in the shower and you do
like this like what like working through
materials i'll walk through arguments
more or whatever
oh now we're [ __ ] getting yeah i can
walk through like uh debates i'm gonna
have or i've had or social points just
what i i work through what i'm thinking
about it
uh and i try to like kind of think of
both points of it just to just i like to
do it just it's a very freeing time for
that reason maybe well you have
arguments in your head with people that
maybe you've never met or arguments that
have never taken place um
oh yeah you do oh public debates of
course in my mind yeah yeah yeah
you know he's trying to open for
seinfeld you know that's true yeah
i'm debating with kramer over his la
said
use it more
you should have smiled michael
i told you mike stand behind you this
whole thing would have blown over mike's
stand behind you
[Music]
oh
i i mean i'm
pills drive pizza crust irish
yeah psycho in the shower yeah i mean
we're checking all the boxes here ever
bought anything at a coffee shop
uh like you ever buy any of the art
hanging on the wall
at a coffee shop or anything like that i
mean merchandise
no um no i have not no
no just not even a i think it's
starbucks i mean i brought like one of
those carry cups
are you a coffee drinker yeah a lot of
it do you do starbucks or dunkin
or like independent what do you do uh
starbucks uh my goal is to drive every
mom and pop business out
so it's only chains i i usually get a
starbucks i don't even like it that much
dunkin donuts is better do you make
coffee at the house yeah but i have a uh
i have an espresso machine nice did he
say dunkin donuts was better hang on a
second yeah yeah i kind of prefer
starbucks i understand yeah yeah it's
the tray yeah it's trashy but you do
have an espresso machine is it good
espresso machine nespresso yeah yeah
it's it's good it's just i i make little
coffees with that my dad gave me a cure
but i hate keurig it tastes like it's
just too watery
yeah so i tried to sell it in my
building and when the woman was supposed
to come up and buy it she goes oh my dad
has one 20 minutes before she was
supposed to purchase mine wait you're
trying to sell the curing machine it was
unused i'm unused it was in my building
i was put on the thing
what yeah that's pretty trashy it's
garbage
yeah yeah yeah i gave it to the door
guys because they have like a break room
i'm like it's
never been used i'm surprised not that
i've ever been to your place but that
your building would have things like
that where you could do those kind of
things yeah they do they have like an on
you know it's like a uh
that is a big new york thing in there
we're getting rid of this dad sure
new building posting yeah yeah um you
know cleaning lady you have a cleaning
lady i do yeah
yeah once a week once a week once a week
yeah
i was so embarrassed too because she
took the cover off my duvet my duvet
cover off by a like comforter and i i
can't even describe to you the amount of
piss stains on my duvet
i can't describe it to you and i said
accidental or oh yeah i'm not that
messed up
[Laughter]
got me
yeah wow oh god you got anything else
i'm i'm no i'm ready to uh yeah i mean
the guy's trash jersey trash
for sure
i thought you were gonna surprise me
with this but now that the shower really
put me over the yeah i don't know if you
should be using irish spring anymore
you're doing well
i know but the other stuff didn't it was
too annoying it didn't have a smell
that's got a nice clean irish
especially if you come from like that's
what i used growing up like and it's
just like you're used to it like i you
know if i use something like buttermilk
i feel like a [ __ ] [ __ ] walking i
got something i need something hard i
got i think i might have something for
you
but
we'll worry about it off there i think i
got a soap for him i know exactly what
that he's going to like it no and it's
classy a gentleman's scent yes
it is okay why are you saying like i
don't believe that i [ __ ] believe you
yeah are you worried it's gonna sell out
like why would you just say what it is
we're not so insane
ladies and gentlemen mr jim norton jim
what do you got coming up anything you
want to folks out there tonight this was
so fun man i'm going to be doing uh
philadelphia helium uh at the end of uh
what oh
i'm literally looking at this
30 years in the business i'm looking at
a pillow across the room
what an ass
hi
i thought you were looking for a
calendar that's it we got to kill him
give him cancer real quick cindy brady
handled the camera better than i do uh i
would say uh i'm gonna be in
philadelphia helium coming up and then
in uh our first week of november i'm
here in new york at caroline's and
december 4th i'm in boca raton at the uh
laughing spree festival uh brian callan
one night that me and uh andrew schultz
on the early in late show it's a great
festival that's it fantastic buddy we
love you thank you i love you guys
coming in fun man really fun thank you
fantastic kippy what do you got for him
uh also we'll be in philadelphia and new
york so get those [ __ ] tickets the
shows are gonna sell out we're only
doing one get em yeah we love you guys
and we'll see you next week peace
it's beekman's beekman soap i've never
heard of it